[Musique]
bon
nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au bout
[Musique]
exemple eh oui mais pas dans la cuisine
attendre
essayez-vous richard des jeux très
inégaux ces deux contrées sur mon but je
vois là bas c'est une fois qu'est ce que
vous faisiez un peu de champagne au
frais d'un prix ce qui m'a fait louis
pour vos affaires
je marque mais quelquefois je reviens de
l'académie à pied ouais je viens de
l'académie s'était dit redouter conquis
jusqu'à la ford no file api extrait je
serai porte dauphine
mais je vais aussi du quartier latin la
porno ville à pied je marche beaucoup
en tous les cas moi vous m'avez fait un
grand plaisir je ne sens pas la seconde
sous voie de la préface que vous avez
ces deux monnaies de ses fabriques et
j'étais très content parce que j'ai
senti une véritable foi vous une par an
voilà ça fait un livre avec une préface
1 2 co mais je tenais beaucoup à le
faire parce qu'il y avait là vraiment
quelqu'un qui croyait à cette conne et
pourquoi pas mais les arguments sont pas
démodé du tout parce que vous savez que
tout le monde a pris ça à l'époque pour
une pause de dandy et oui mais en fait
pas du tout parce que c'est en 86 a fait
pratiquement 20 ans a fait 19 ans et je
professe toujours les mêmes arguments
sur la monarchie et louis mary j les
femmes et traiter toute façon maintenant
qui a maintenant qu'il ya l'europe il ya
six monarchies en europe à l'autre vous
écrivez sur quoi
si j'étais un livre secret parce que
maintenant je n'annonce plus mes livres
parce qu'on était y définit pas du tout
parce qu'il ya quelques années j'avais
commencé un livre j'avais indiqué le
sujet à mon éditeur lequel l'a fait
pasienky communiqué dans la presse mais
et puis on a su que j'ai trouvés solides
mais moi arriver au bout de trois cents
par je me suis dit ce sujet nul je me
suis complètement trompé j'arrête je
n'ai rien n'est plus publié celui talons
maintenant je ne dis plus la personne ce
que je fais avant que ce soit fini la
télévision alors à la télévision
syrienne ma vie je les fait délibérément
léger aussi vous savez quitter la radio
les raison très simple de rendre
l'opération est mon cas de l'homme m'a
dit est la phrase est très belle 1 je
vous interdis maintenant les stress
d'obligations
m
je sois soir quand avez-vous bon soir
c'était avant ça va je vais bien ouais
il ya deux cours qu'elle a deux coups de
kohat l'un à oui oui alors situé ce qui
est génial c'est il fait alain decaux
raconte j'ai dit ouais je le regarde ça
fait dix minutes qui me raconte des
histoires d
[Musique]
et bonsoir c'est aussi quatre ans mercy
oh
vous étiez napoleoni ce mois qu'en
maintenant j'ai j'étais entre napoléon
mien napoléonien mais ce que je ne
savais pas du tout à la restauration de
lempire quoi j'ai vu les deux très
bonnes relations des relations vraiment
le vent d'amis qui est le dernier prince
napoléon qui déclarait il ya quelques
années et savent que j'aime beaucoup sa
femme est une femme admirable et oui
mais mais je n'étais pas bonapartiste
d'ailleurs le prince un ballon lui même
n'était pas de la partie sans jamais
parce qu'il était à venir une éthique je
vivais napoléon soir là
et
in the kitchen vélo et équitable et c
est maurice et a6 à lui
non
sur la place tien fait fort en plastique
ce qui est génial sur ce qu'ils valent
toujours super bien mais c'est vrai je
vais bien attends attends attends je
vais voir la poche à mort quand on est
dans la merde parce qu'ils énoncent
attendus tous les jours ça va je suis un
bon jour un symbole slf
ça va être un garçon il fait
j'espère un des deux mains tout à quoi
je dirais qu'on est plus je suis pas le
père
ouais c'est pas moi mais pareil j'arrive
pas à re mettre un visage sur le père tu
fais tu produis un film tourné un film
s'appelle rtt jean paul rouve et sophie
marceau un peu difficile à financer
ouais on tournera si tout va bien en
en février voilà en afrique du sud
grande comédie d'aventurés puis après je
fais 2 to 2 3 autres trucs
j'essayais marc levy je sais que tu
apprécies beaucoup et bien sûr pour nous
c'est inventé que les mains et est
pourtant ce qu il est un bon projet il
va réaliser
il va réaliser cette messe est mort loi
non mais qui s'est mis à faire des
livres il était choisie était architecte
newey
il s'est mis à faire des livres il a
fait que des best-sellers peut-être que
pendant un temps défini proxité je vais
parler un peu la suède des blockbusters
ya plein perdus et elle ce bien de
s'inquiéter je suis serbe montigny
insultant oui c'est vrai qu'un film
d'aventurés s'appelant rtt c'est voilà
c'est on est on est heureux ne savait
pas paralyser l'autre jour la gérer
c'est un marché pas marché ouais ouais
ça a marché restait bien bien paradis
déjà des produits beaucoup en fin de
compte plus de rien de rien il ya eu
trafic d'influencé bon ouais mais tu
sais que ça marche super bien à la télé
avant ouais c'est comme tu es prime
c'est pourtant accompli à l'otan mais si
tu fais une groupie de tout et cover de
sa femme s'amuse même moi même depuis un
mois mais moi ça va je t'ai vu chez
thierry et j'ai vu le nombre de couleurs
c'était ahurissant présidentielle à quai
mais ça c'est sûr la cena
ça plane pour moi c'est dans l'histoire
donc j'en ai quatre années après midi à
l'est encore si on va y aller ou pas n'y
vont pas
[Musique]
oui mon t-shirt noir comme étant bon bah
c'est une grande date parce que vous
savez qu'il voulait tous vous rencontrer
alors pourquoi vous les rencontrez
absolument alain decaux alors jean paul
hévin pas parce que on écrit un dut
d'histoire ce qu'on a décidé d'arrêter
d'être comique d'être historien ouais
ils voulaient qu on est tous qui n'ont
livre est rigoureusement exemple mais je
comprends pas pourquoi vous avez parlé
de tout ça mais alors je vais vous dire
la vérité
tout ce que vous avez écrit je le sais
et depuis longtemps
je sais que tout ce que vous écrivez est
vrai mais je ne pouvais pas le dire ça
vous jean fin je peux dire la vérité
elle est dans votre livre reste du
château fort
la définition est très éminents c'est là
qu'elle va difficile c'est tout aussi je
te rappelle alors rappelé la définition
du japon devra sur moi je vais au moyen
âge parce que je crois que les châteaux
fort sévère ils bloquent faut voir c'est
une historienne tout s'est fait en deux
jours surviennent
non je suis arrêté houba houba
tchouvachov ivan basso tu vas schaller
je suis pas julien les châteaux forts
maintenant alors
on se rend compte de ce canevas mason a
fait signer non je voudrais montrer à
mes convives en question voilà parce que
c'est un livre illustré à sa wii et bien
sûr qu'on en a pour son argent il n'y a
pas que des lettres
alors voilà il donc on explique pour la
différence entre le château et le
château fort le château fort est tout
simplement beaucoup plus costaud alors
que le château est beaucoup moins
costauds n'arrivait jamais été déterrée
il faut actuellement clavier charrier
sur vos amis ils vous ont attribué il
vous aura attribué une préface que quand
même quelque chose oui on s'est vu dans
l'obligation de faire un fond la préface
cndd et du saas et au début mais tu vois
tu
tombé et vous avez tous les trucs du mec
qui dit qu'un quoi mon propos bon après
il ya un avant propos voilà ça c'est pas
la préface si c'est si simple
moi je veux c'est la teneur alors
messieurs j'ai le regret de refuser
votre demande de prêt face car votre
ouvrage comporte de nombreuses
inexactitudes notamment à la page il ya
quatre lignes de pages de fautes je me
vois dans l'obligation de porter plainte
auprès de votre éditeur pour sa cage le
patrimoine culturel français y accéder
mais mes consternant de salutation signé
alain decaux avec un s avec la nes et
c'est pour ça que j'ai un argument pour
mon procès mais en plus on me prête un
nom qui n'est pas le mien c'est ce qu'il
affirme savary alors il a fait une
préface d'un livre pour moi oui oui oui
alors ils pensaient qu'ils allaient
gagner oui c'est un livre où il vint
livres d'histoire mais le sérieux et il
a demandé la préface est bien que
bonapartiste vous n'êtes pas là par
napoléoniennes à part une liste
la distinction entre la partie sénat
peut devenir si vous la polonia c'est
quand des rentes souvenir de napoléon
oui personnage de napoléon qu'on est
amis on est à mon avis c'est difficile
de pas faire ne pas l'avouer pas
l'admirer mais mais en revanche je sais
pas on n'est pas partisan du oui à la
restauration de lempire d'années de la
différence entre 20 junien et vaginite
c'est un peu du même genre alors quand
j'étais enfant avant la guérilla 20
parties de la partie madrelle et des
structures avec un comité qui se
réunissent et mehdi mort et il a disparu
avec la guerre les derniers descendants
wisson ont disparu il ya pas si
longtemps les sens minable
hier dès 6 heures demain oui messieurs
clergé déviant vrai mais en tout cas ça
me laisse descendre à napoléon il ya un
grand généalogistes que j'ai connus qui
n'est plus malone qui s'appelait joseph
valence elle qui a fait des travaux jeu
mais qui débouche sur des choses
extraordinaires
idei midi montre parmi les dessins en
napoléon est un livre capa qui est paris
à 20 ans que l'un d'eux et pas seulement
dans le métro c'est vrai c'est
parfaitement vrai c'est pas de la rue
allard connaissez l'histoire du comte
léon oui c'est un descendant nous conte
les ou si tu peux rien
je voulais raconter ou faux tampon
spécial
le concluant je t'explique napoléon est
marié avec joséphine il peut pas avoir
d'enfant et à ce moment là je les fines
qui avait eu deux enfants hortense et le
prince eugène dit à napoléon c'est toi
qui peux pas voir l'enfant puisque moi
j'en ai eu deux avant toi et toi tu n'as
jamais eu et la soeur de napoléon seul
qu'habiter à l'elysée je crois que c'est
pauline non oui pauline qui dit anna
paule en écoute on va faire un essai je
vais te prêter une copine tu vas voir si
tu si tu peux la mettre enceinte on va
voir si ça vient le top-6 adams la femme
c'est bien de l'impératrice
c'est bien de joséphine est donc
napoléon fait un enfant à 7 c'est quoi
c'est une dame de compagnie mademoiselle
de la nouvelle venue voilà et donc il
lui fait un enfant et sept enfants
évidemment la fille lui demande de le
reconnaître il refuse de reconnaître
l'enfant mais il accepte quand même que
l'enfant s'appelle léon il lui donne la
moitié de son nom et ses enfants le
comte léon a traversé tout le 19e siècle
et quand il ya eu napoléon iii au
pouvoir évidemment il était très riche
évidemment puisque son sens son oncle
lui lui donner de l'argent mais quand
après il ya eu la fin du second empire
il est plus d'argent donc à la fin du
19e siècle dans certains bistrots de
montmartre on voyait le le comte léon
avec un chapeau sur la tête la main
comme ça et on lui donner du pognon sur
les mecs dans le bistrot lui a été de
napoléon 60 c'était pas fini parce
qu'ils riel l'on continue ou de votre
temps avant qu'on leur connaissait comme
le descendant de l'empereur est signée
tellement d'autographes qu'un beau jour
il a signé chanel jusqu'à signer des
tickets de métro fait qu'il y avait plus
de risques soirée parfaite donc c'était
un descendant du contraire oui il était
apiculteurs oui et ça je trouve ça
merveilleux c'est vrai que la veille
contre lyon il a il a fini dans la
misère en fait le premier courrier le
premier oui oui oui le concret on vous y
connaissez vous fait quoi comme le
séjour de châtaignes canard pouvait pas
savoir qu'ils feraient s'ils sont degrés
en plein mois d'octobre aujourd'hui
noualhat 10v fe un repas c'est un repas
d'automne lors de l'automne exactement
en quelle année il a fait chaud comme un
serveur avait bon appétit
là faut reconnaître c'est la première
fois que lorsqu'on va faire toi tu va
meubler la conversation
c'est tombé sur toi toi tu vas me mais
la conversation pendant comprenant
qu'ondine un allez vas-y une question
que je me pose tout le temps c'est
est-ce que je t'appelle plastique ou
est-ce que ces 25 ans + 27 ans que je
fais vraiment que ça même si on voit
attaquer quoi tu fais partie sale voilà
et plastique ça a toujours du mal quoi
cela je propose d'un exercice plastique
plastic place
placez pas c'est que ça qu'on veut à
monsieur charest bravo à la soupe énorme
parce que j'aime bien le tracé des prêts
si le galbe des cuisses
mardi l'actrice voit un petit cochon
comme ça c'est les robins des bois qui
m'ont amené beaucoup de gens trouvaient
sous donné la succès lui sourit à la jad
il fait la conversation
moi je connais une [ __ ] mais qui est
très bien galbées bravo à la soupe c'est
génial merci
est ce qui te souviens de mes nuits bien
sûr il me dit allez robin des bois un
petit cochon j'dida quoi il a fait des
bourses aussi pour accompagner le cochon
à cause de robin des bois et à ses
impôts est obligé de surveiller un peu
le menu ses récifs et un cochon il
invite bernard henri lévy sur la radio
je me suis renseigné on m'a dit que tu
manges et je mange de tout tu mange de
tout je mange de tout ça
je veux pas se le cacher battus mange
casher toi nous mettons tapeta communion
pour toi bien sûr mais je vais mais j'ai
renoncé à la foi catholique pour aller
vers la fois tu dis ah ouais t'as faim
j'exhorte bien sûr je le crois bien
entendu je crois heureusement je crois
il ya un rabat qui m'a dit un truc
magnifique j'avais ma divisible on lui
disait est ce qu'on est ce qu'on peut
croire en dieu mais il lui a dit est ce
que vous croyez en l'amour
ouais mec dit oui donc vous pouvez
croire en dieu vous c'est très jeune et
c'est vrai mais je trouve que cette
sensation voir cette sensation de croire
madame 1 après tout à quelques jours de
la semaine et terence pour quelqu'un qui
est sûrement quelque chose qui se passe
au dessus de la même manière voilà
ensuite qu'on la confonde avec la foi
catholique de la foi juive je suis
j'espère que tu crois en l'amour en tout
cas mais bien sûr je pense qu'on craint
c'est plus contacts mais je crois que
dalia dans l'amour de la spiritualité tu
peux retrouver dans cette spiritualité
dans la croyance en dieu voilà je
m'arrête je dis des conneries
moi je suis croyant et je pense que
c'est très important de baisser la tête
devant quelque chose c'est à dire qu'à
partir du moment où vous l'être humain
se croient tout permis il fait des pires
conneries tu fais sauver c'est la tête
de vendée devant des tas de choses aussi
qui ne sont pas de l'ordre du divin tu
peut justement baisser la tête devant
l'amour tu peux baisser la tête et
pâteux son tir surpuissant
moi qui suis non croyant que les gens
c'est ça c'est dans l'eau ce sont
surpuissants et et la religion n'est pas
je crois pas être indulgent le remet à
sa place je trouve un
une bombe atomique en me disant au nom
de dieu tu as droit de tuer c'est une si
la magie non mais sans aller jusqu'aux
frais qui souvent on associe ce on
associe les deux déjà on n'oblige
personne à croire et on veut sur domactu
pas
mais au-delà de ça tu peux à un moment
fort dans le monde
jose il ya qu'il y a quelque chose
dessus de moi qui éventuellement me
guide ou et quelques qui éventuellement
m'a donné quelque chose bâton c'est pas
une personne sera qu'à la fin et encore
et encore j'ai découvert il ya peu de
temps une phrase de victor hugo qui me
hante
parce qu'il se trouve que j'ai aussi la
foi et cette phrase est la suivante je
ne crois pas qu'une prière puisse se
perdre
laon qui dit cela n'est pas baptisé et
n'est pas catholique
il n'y a aucune religion il dira à sa
mort je refuse les prières des religions
je les demande à tous les hommes
eh ben j'ai dit que cette phrase est
formé d'un mois elle m'aide napoléon
napoléon était croyant à la napoléon
il a dit je désire que mes cendres
reposent sur les bancs à la scène dans
ce pays que j'ai tant aimé
il a reçu l'extrême onction mais je
pense que c'était politique je pense
qu'il voulait pour montrer au monde
qu'ils étaient morts dans la foi sauter
son testament
je meurs dans la religion catholique
apostolique et romaine dans laquelle je
suis né
donc c'est un élément mais ça n'a pas
empêché de faire déplacer droit puis
d'ouvrir d'ouvrir notre dame et de rapa
qu'il est la fois vous pensez qu'il
était politique jusqu'à la mort
oui c'est incroyable ça absolument puis
tout ce qu'il a fait à sainte hélène et
politique quand il va vendre son
argenterie qu'il a rapporté de paris
c'est de l'argent massif c'est sec
c'est une argenterie qui voue beaucoup
d'argent qui forment l île rémy dans ses
bagages ils en portaient tous la série
et il veut le vendre
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils avant la 6
millions dont 6 millions hors dans une
banque de paris
j'ai lafitte et sailly et c'est ce qui
permettra de faire les led qui va faire
à ses fils elle est il la vend pour que
tous les médias on n'avait pas conduit
les journaux du moun 10 napoléon réduits
à se vendre par l'angleterre s'est passé
pas laisser un geste politique immense
n'était pas normal c'est un
extraterrestre napoléon non mais sérieux
quand on voit ce qu'il a fait c'est qui
a dit là la façon la plus extraordinaire
dont était pétri l'argile humaine c'est
chateaubriand
elle te voyais juste mais c'est ça
sérieusement napoléon est ce que c'est
pas l'homme le plus étonnant qu'ils
aient jamais existé
moi je pense le suisse aura une phrase
de pascal pascal qui parle d espoir et
napoléon mais il y dit il existe des
esprits vaste 1
et moi j'ai dit cette phrase s'applique
à la peau noire son intervention il
c'est un esprit vaste quand on regarde
tout ce qu'il écrit
on va on va rééditer sa correspondance
et moi j'ai un exemplaire du second
empire la correspondance de de la polo
et orrit à 13 13 au 17 volumes on ouvre
au hasard on dit comment ces petits
plats à plus tous les jours est clair
tout ça à dicter souvent il ya quatre
titres cassette à la famille puis mais
il le fait et en même temps ils gagnent
des batailles en même temps gouvernent
l'europe et on sait et en même temps par
l'ons
les mesdames il baise ce sont des filles
d'aujourd'hui une semaine et ce à chaque
fois le mot volontairement je l'avais
prévu à la vente
il baisse certains pour montrer qu à
l'académicien français est capable en
public de dire il ya une chose qui est
un souvenir que j'ai il avait nous
déjeunions un soir chez moi avec andré
deux fois ça mais bien parce qu'il y
avait rencontré dieu dans une autre date
et où s'est clos des dirigeants mais
c'est plutôt qu'au sahara derrière lui
alors il voit je reviens j'ai ça tienne
la place la correspondance de la pole en
il s'approche edit ah bon j'ai dit ben
oui et 10 à quoi ça sert de
correspondance de l'apollon judy chaire
andré vous prenez un volume au hasard et
vous gardez au hasard il où il y est dit
ah oui et quelle modernité
je dis pourquoi vous dites ça et il me
fait rire monsieur le grand maréchal
je vais entrer en campagne d'hiver je
tiens à ce que mes armes et sont soit
abondamment équipés de kapok qu'elle
veut lever
ce qu'on sait pas sur la scène du cirque
c'est qu'en fait ils avaient des manies
l'avait fait avec des marionnettes à sa
mère vient de dire il david a tout à
tour david a tout corriger et lui avait
répété la scène du sacre avec des
mannequins quoi mannequins comme ça vous
savez pas ça parce que franchement tu
vois bien bossé deux coups c'est faux et
c'est grâce à placer que je dois ma
seule et unique rébellion envers mes
parents à l'époque jeudi à l'époque mais
c'est un certain moment de ma vie j'ai
écouté plastic bertrand et kiss c'est
bien ce qui a qui étaient dans le vert
et j'avais le 33 tours aux way et mon
père menacé de me casser et la seule
fois où je me suis revenu j'étais
d'accord tu me casse je casse ton disque
de saint preux il me fait ok d'accord et
depuis j'ai eu l'appel et je suis devenu
un homme aussi bravo merci presto parce
que huawei plastique a l'air cool et
très remuant fait plastique a été le
support d'un certain nombre de
rebellions c'était une parodie
quand j'ai fait ça va j'ai très bien
qu'ils étaient malcom mclaren alors
qu'en france personne avec qui c'était
est ce qu'un mal comme qu'inventer tout
ça et qui a vendu sa aux majors pour
faire une espèce de mouvement entre
guillemets social quoi tu dois alors que
c'est complètement bidon quoi ces
industries simplement tu avais tu avais
un petit blouson rose
oui très très très sèche et nourrice
alors vraiment percé ou ne sera pas tu
l'aimés plastique
moi j'aimais bien fun juste un peu punk
le père l'adolescent soit bon je te
crois aussi s'exprimer crash mais tu
vois pas at il dit bon ça plane pour moi
c'était un truc rigolo mais tous les
gens que mais johnny rotten où les gens
vivront les vrais peuple tu vois vous
les vrais punks entre guillemets mais
les grands peuples qu'ils adorent sa
femme pour moi je vais parfaitement
compris ce que c'était que c'est le
parodie et que c'était l'ultime chanson
après ça il fait c'est pas la peine de
faire autre chose et c'était la chanson
le team du punk et après ça tu oublies
quoi après on passe à autre chose
laissez moi en toi t'as pas la
crédibilité musicale des autres quand
même un hostie jeudi passé à produire de
la peine qui est une en admettant même
moi je chante pas crédibilité moi c'est
ça que j'adore les robes hervé qu'il a
une crédibilité musicale complètement
fou la crédibilité mitterrand qu'il faut
avoir lu les souvenirs de son frère aîné
robert qui raconte leur enfance commune
et cetera ici viennent de province ils
sont dans une maison religieuse pour
faire leurs études supérieures et de
vaugirard
et là ils vont à la messe presque chaque
jour
c'est robert ses mémoires c'est
naturellement journal il a aménagé
parce qu'il peut pas se souvenir de tant
détails dit je vois je vois frédéri pas
freiné s'approchait de la table cela et
j'admire la manière dont ils rentrent
pénétré jusqu'au fond de l'âme parce
qu'il vient
santé alors bien sûr il a évolué il à l
annuler
il n'est plus devenu le même homme mais
je me demande si quand on a vécu ça on
peut tout évacuer
je crois pas que vous dire que non et
remercie moi je suis l'exemple j'ai été
élevé s'il est qu orange et tout renier
tout abandonner j'ai craché sur tout et
à l'âge de 40 ans est revenue 110 puisse
faire aimer mes 10 à comparer à des gens
c'est que ça revient pas je fais comme
ça ce rôle de ses revenus quand j'ai
connu de grandes difficultés dans la vie
d'un second je me suis raccroché à je me
suis raccroché à je me suis pas
raccrocher la religion m'a aidé à ce
moment là mais ses revenus de l'enfance
du très très loin oui ça revient mais le
fait que un jour où j'allais à l'elysée
j'ai passé par la vie mais il se trouve
que j'étais membre du conseil l'à-propos
nina que j allais parce que c'était le
ciel qu'est ce que je vois sortir par
une porte
comme dirait hugo d'éroder et je vois
jean guitton j'ai dit mon cher ami
qu'est ce que vous faites là dit je
rends visite à quelqu'un de temps à eau
et j'ai su que c'était mitterrand qui
voulaient voir jean guitton avec cette
question étrange
il espère que jean guitton philosophe
chrétien lui prouveraient que dieu
existe et jean vitaux essayé mais
humaine incluant un 1 homme de foi a des
doutes
vous savez moi je pense toujours à ce
qu'a écrit et jean andré maurois dans un
service complètement oublié qui sape et
mu poulet délivrant dialogue entre celui
qui à la fois et pas celui qui n'a pas
la foi alors vous avez la foi oui aux
curieux mais alors vous devez quand même
douté une fois par jour
celui qui à la fois pas du tout ah bon
et alors cent fois par jour oui l'homme
qui a la foi qui ne douterait pas je
trouve ça bizarre je pense que le pape
doute je pense que c'est insensé de dire
ça mais je pense que c'est il n'est pas
possible de ne pas douter ces choses là
sont pas certaines années prouve la
grande question c'est quand même seule
question à laquelle j'avais personne a
trouvé de réponse je suis enceinte
il ya plus et une en rien moi je te jure
que le sérieux n'est pas digne va
m'accuser temps mais pas hors de
question et je suis juive je suis give
alors j'ai entendu le jour à la radio un
type qui disait il raconté pendant la
guerre fils avait été poursuivi par la
gestapo puis j'ai eu des guise
je sais je suis juive
sauf si tu abandonnes et qu'il est
recueilli par une famille cachée risque
de la mi novembre 2004 il peut être
baptisé en même temps c'est à dire que
j'ai écrit pour les enfants des livres
parce que j'avais envie de faire des
livres pour les enfants parce que
j'avais moi même des enfants mais
j'aimerais jésus-christ raconte aux
enfants écrit par vous c'est la bible
aussi et je le fais à l'envers
cette exceptionnelle et là bon j'ai j'ai
écrit ce que je pensais que on savait où
point de vue historique et ses défauts
restent quoi il en reste beaucoup parce
que l'un la bible hébraïque reflète un
certain nombre d'événements qui sont
historiques
elle reflète aussi la croyance d'un
peuple pendant des siècles et des
siècles
c'est très important et c'est là où je
me suis rendu compte que le
pressionnisme je verrai du monde compte
plutôt est réellement les ricky et du
judaïsme dans le droit-fil l'os dans le
totalement droit-fil ce que les graisses
parce que jésus est juif
j'ai fait dactylographié au manuscrit
sur jésus à quelqu'un un homme charmant
et qui avait été dans l'armée qui avait
été champion de dactylographie dans
l'armée d'israël c'est vrai mais qui dit
mais comment jésus était juif
j'ai dit oui vous le saviez pas à l'enam
non pas du tout vous pensiez
arabi bédouins gdim izik et vive toul
alors quand j'ai ajouté pendant plus de
dix ans il n'y a eu de chrétiens que des
juifs parce que après la mort des
résumés les premiers de la can se sont
acharnés qu'à une chose c'est convertir
leurs frais il disait le messie était
annoncé nous on sait qu'on l'a eu
il faut qu'on dise à l'offrir et ce
n'est qu'au bout de plus de 10 ans que
saint paul pour ça que j'ai écrit sur
lui
saint-paul lui a pensé qu'il était temps
d'en parler aux autres là ce qu'on
appelait les païens et ça a été très dur
parce que les les juifs chrétiens un peu
plus intégristes il faut bien dire à
l'origine voulait pas qu'on allait
parler ou p1 c'était entre nous est à
faire là et on est allé au plus à l'est
pas ni le christianisme s'est répandue
partout
et voilà mais c'est pas qu'on l'aimé
mais je donne dans mon lit dans mon
dernier livre sur saint paul une simple
observation elle va pas elle va pas très
loin et c'est une simple envers ce jeudi
dans la messe catholique d'aujourd'hui
il ya des textes peuvent obligatoirement
dans toutes les paroisses du monde
on doit dire ça commence par un extrait
de la bible drik un prophète isaïe ou
anneau donc juifs
ça suit par un texte de saint paul juif
ça continue par l'évangile
les quatre évangélistes sont juifs donc
là maistre catholique et entre des temps
ya des absolus le psaume est juif la
messe catholique est entièrement faite
sur des textes juifs et la plupart de
ceux qui vont ne savent pas ce qui les
retient j'ai tord le cou à
l'antisémitisme
c'est absurde absolument justement de
reclasser jésus dans dans son judaïsme
est-ce qu'il était est ce qu'il est et
rabin est ce qu'il était et ce qu'il a
eu un frère est ce que son frère était
jacques ya qu à williamsville et cetera
et cetera sans faille arrêter jacques
jacques soeur parce que c'est démontré
aujourd'hui conseiller livre remarquable
d'un historien de l'art de religion lui
de formation du bernal qui à écrire une
démonstration éblouissante sur le fait
qu'au japon le premier évêque chrétien
était le frère de jésus
ici c'est incroyable comme certains
bouquins qu'on pourrait appeler un peu
de gars comme davinci code ont créé tout
un tas de remous et tout un tas de
recherche et tout d'un coup il ya
d'autres recherchent beaucoup plus
scientifique qui ont vu le jour où qu'on
a pu voir la télévision si on a commencé
à s'intéresser à s intéresser à tout ça
et détruit des choses qui sortent on
sait que peut-être il a eu il a eu une
femme en tout cas qu'une femme
l'accompagné que ça merde donc sa mère a
mis au monde à un frère dont il ya les
yeux il a eu plus elle a eu plus il ya
eu plusieurs frères donc automatiquement
l a pas fait ça tout seul
voilà il ya plein de choses qui sont qui
sont là en gestation ne sont plus tôt
vraiment intéressante et qui vont qui
devrait vous plaire qui ne devrait que
le judaïsme et le christianisme doivent
même chose tout à fait prêt mais c'est
ce que jean paul ii a
[Applaudissements]
la synagogue synagogue demander pardon
et tu me faut c'est qu'il faut c'est
d'accord avec vous vraiment je pense est
très important moi je mise beaucoup pour
c'est pour ça que le combat des
américains en ce moment et en passant
par mel gibson et son film un moment
certains biens comme un message assez
bizarre alors que justement jean paul 2
se veut enfin demande le pardon au même
moment on ré incluses et des juifs de
2,2 et j'ai fait ce que j'avais dit à
tarak ben ammar à l'époque quand il
était venu parler du film de mel gibson
j'avais dit que ça ça reprenait les
choses où l on était à l'époque avant
vatican ii à l'époque de pile 10 et que
finalement vatican ii avait nettoyé tout
ça que la visite du pape à la synagogue
avoir m'avait nettoyer tout ça est que
ce film re re re gratter déplairait
ouvrait des plaies qui étaient
antérieurs qui étaient des histoires qui
remontait à happy dit c'est que
finalement on n'avait pas besoin de ça
dans le vrai problème aujourd'hui c'est
le problème des intégristes américain
qui kibo qui sont derrière george bush
ah oui et qui font un bout absolument
monstrueux lapin circle dans les écoles
on enlève des livres on est proche de
l'autodafé certaines fois on interdit
des films est alternée ah oui ma
sélection il faut sévir
c'est le créationnisme cette création
non mais on revient à des c'est à dire
que des multiples vanity fair qui était
chez toi y'a pas longtemps tu es et si
c'est exactement ce qu'il dit
le 11 septembre a permis aux états unis
de remettre une chape de plomb plus
forte que celle du maccarthysme bien sûr
beaucoup plus fort c'est incroyable les
gens viennent surprise de l'extrême
droite américaine comme 40 a été la
divine surprise les
de l'extrême droite française c'est à
dire que d'un seul coup on vous avait
bien dit que le front populaire c'est
une connerie regarder on a perdu la
guerre bat maintenant mais pétain soyez
gentil c'est exactement là où celle ci
aura permis à la droite qui coûtait pas
ce qu'on peut tu peut dénoncer ton
voisin les ans je pense qu'il est anti
américain bon on va nous mettre sur
écoute tu te retrouves sur l'écouté et
puis voilà c'est patriot act pratique
patriot act et il ya il ya quelque chose
de soja sion qui est un retour en
arrière qui est là qui est qui et mais
qui est inquiet probants et après avoir
vécu woodstock l'été des fleurs le
flower power
on fait tous l'amour etc etc après les
années sida tout d'un coup on y donne en
attention c'est comme ça que vous en
êtes arrivé là il faut faire attention
on va tous se remettre dans le droit
chemin prions ensemble
as tu pris pas tu sors donc je propose
que maintenant c'est pas réjouissant
voulait d énorme pétard va semer des
fleurs dans les cheveux et on va chanter
médicaux tout simple vous pouvez faire
une part tous très rapide jouer ses
matches je comprends dominicale du tout
non non on prend le dessert tu sais que
je vais jamais un cursus et après après
un petit peu importe j'ai une chose à
vous demander quand on faisait les
missions quand je regarde quand j'étais
gamin alain decaux raconte c'était en
direct s'était enregistré déjà ça a duré
20 ans dont onze ans attend 6 ans arrêté
il ya un souvenir est ce que c'est fou
et vous étiez en plan fixe
oui oui vous étiez que en plan fixe oui
là vous captive y est les gens avec une
seule caméra aurait d'accord avec une
seule caméra
attention il y avait quand même des
illustrations week-end le patron temps
c'est pas de rentrer mais nous prenons
tous par coeur avant japonais est rien
ces criminels pas raconter non je
faisais cela me remplit c'est la tête si
je mens remplissait s'imprégner m'engage
à un mois un mois de lecture sur le
sujet après quoi dans la semaine qui
précédait
je faisais un plan en disant je vais
dire ça dans l'ordre ce plan est très
réduit qui était d'abord assez important
avec est réduit en une seule par la
veille de l'émission et le matin
l'émission est là l'après-midi
j'arrivais à 4 heures je voyais mon
équipe et je leur donnais le texte qui
était manuscrits ça avait été fait et on
le photocopier pour les distribuer à
toute l'équipe et là je ne faisais pas
la répétition
1 parce que j'avais fait au début et au
début j'avais répété on avait ensuite
fait l'émission direct et le régisseur
qui était dans la cabine tout à fait on
m'a dit ah c'était surtout vient cet
après midi à monsieur decaux je dis
pourquoi vous dites ça rabat parce que
c'était le mieux cet après midi alors
j'ai dit alors on le répètera plus
et votre anecdote concorde avec ce que
dominique notre ancien patron nous avait
balancé une fois en répétition répéter
nos sketches l'après midi et il passait
ici et il nous disait ce soir vous serez
à chier et on disait mais comment tu le
sais est visée parce que là vous étiez
bon il ya une règle et un jour un jeu
vous avez été dérangés par quelque chose
mais c'est la seule fois où vous avez eu
un trou j'ai eu un trou terrible parce
que c'était le moment où on a voulu me
changer de caméra sous mes yeux
moi je regardais l'objectif dernière
l'objectif y avait heureusement quelques
millions de personnes et je savais
qu'elle était là quand des groupes m'a
dit faut que tu enregistres parce qu'on
veut ajouter des images ça j'ai fait
parce qu'il le voulait mais mais cela
dit je regrette qu'elle direct parce que
je sentais avec le dire et je sentais ce
genre de telles reliques sentais très
fort et je leur parlais tout à coup
revient même être une nouvelle caméra la
chance tous mes yeux horreur absolue est
alors quand le cadreur change de caméras
par la nouvelle parce que la scène la
première était open et qui passe de
l'autre côté
et quand il me fait comme ça c'est à
dire que mon regard a quitté la première
fois je porte mon regard à l'autre et
justement je sais plus ce que je suis
une fois une fois en vain non
franchement vous en veut aux quatre
couleurs faut reconnaître qu'au fond
c'est vrai que le tuyau à la musique en
live tout de suite
batteur aussi ça pour ça j'ai déjà nous
tient le président asie lui à l'origine
il est batteur premier boulot c'est
batteur j'ai même une licence de concert
de flûte traversière à l'école normale
de paris savent que lui l'a pas acheté à
l'académie vous on est à quelques
lettres à l'académie nous sommes allés
très je suis entré à la presse
en 1985
c'est à dire vous êtes actionnaire
comment
il faut un dictionnaire ils sont pas
pressés ensemble qu'on aura fini la 9e
édition du dictionnaire en 2010 - et
vous discutez a beaucoup bayrou c'est
pour ça que c'est par les lieux du tout
l'académie c'est plutôt rigolo parce que
sur les définitions on parle du
dictionnaire précédent nous sommes à la
neuvième édition il ya là une 9 de piste
mais russe 16 135 bon on travaille sur
l'ancien et ont seulement quels sont les
mots qu'il faut expulser parce qu'ils ne
se parlent plus du tout c'est on est
c'est un travail inquiétant parce que se
dit est ce qu'ils sont vraiment un
succès est-ce qu'il ya encore des gens
qui le dit mais il ya une enquête qui
est faite pour nous par deux
spécialistes qui lisent tous les
journaux qui l'étouffé émission qui nous
font un rapport en dire honnêtement
depuis 15 ans second n'a jamais plus été
prononcé en revanche je peux vous dire
qu'alors notre rôle encore plus
difficile est d'accepter les mots
nouveaux
parce que les mots nouveaux n'est ce pas
tellement du peuple inès dans la rue etc
on fabrique pas les mots nouveaux
ils viennent comme ça c'est largo au
début et alors il se passe des années et
à force de faire de la bouffe quand même
le monde alors il faut décider qui doit
entrer et là il ya une responsabilité
comme c'est une vraie responsabilité
d'en faire sans réagir comme prenez par
exemple les rip
oui les ripoux à mon avis sont entrés
c'est plus de 5 points à 10 pouces et
les pouilles pour les policiers mais on
dans les jours et je suis là dans le
dictionnaire de l'académie les ripoux
militer pour n'y est pas encore mais moi
je vais militer pour les ripoux parce
que je trouve que les ripoux c'est
entrer dans la langue vous avez dans les
journaux le commissaire entre elles
convaincu d'être ripoux qu on ne dit pas
qu'on vrai plus d'être tout y passe et
entrer complètement dans la norme
alors là on les prend on prend les mots
qui sont nouveaux alors c'est très
amusant parce que on discute entre nous
il ya les conservateurs qui dit jamais
ce mot là doit être conservée pour
l'avenir il est beau balzac l'a utilisé
ce serait vrai que virer des mots du
dictionnaire c'est que cette possibilité
mais il faut les villes ainsi ce qu'ils
n'ont pas du tout c'est sur ce tiers
richelieu bagarre nous a chargés de
consacrer l'usa nous sommes obligés de
dire quels sont les vrais gars dans la
mise à jour un jour quand on présente à
laquelle amy c'est le jeudi après-midi
le mot import export
oui alors définition l'émail et bien et
puis on our du bon personne ne dit rien
mais du tour d'oman la parole il faut
dire qu on est des copains dans la
plupart on vous voit le post it war
depuis vingt ans mais on se dit monsieur
et vous alors du tour dit monsieur le
directeur
on y passe tous tournent est élu pour
trois mois chacun diact monsieur c'est
comme à la ferme
copier l'académie du vénéré alors
monsieur le directeur
je vais vous dire une chose j'apprends
que vous acceptez que nous acceptons
avant une soirée et widgets personnes là
mon cher monsieur le direct
j'ai parcouru nos vies j'ai éprouvé de
grands malheurs
c'est vrai qu'il a été fait prisonnier
il le dit qui s'était évadé il a eu des
malheurs hâtives ou sa fille honor s'il
ne le dit pas mais on pense tous et diva
la paf paf tous les malheurs que je ne
pensais pas à l'âge où je suis par une
série que sous le portrait du cardinal
de richelieu 30 sous laquelle on nous
proposera un forfait aux extrêmes deux
associations qui ne font pas un mot
c'est là tout le monde est bouleversé
voilà le directeur musique l'inattendu
monsieur monsieur du tout quand parce
qu'avant il ya la commission du
dictionnaire qui siègent quelques jours
avant quelques semaines avant et qui
prête présente les choses à la compagnie
bleu dit quand la commission du
dictionnaire assiégée nous avons été
unanimes à dire import export n'est pas
tolérable et nous allons le rayé et
quelqu'un a dit d'entre nous gardons le
jusqu'à la semaine prochaine ce sera
l'occasion d'une excellente attire dans
ces mesures
et alors est comment je me fais des
blagues c'est dans cette maison c'est
trop alain ce que vous avez pensé à
écrire une pièce comique là-dessus la
scion sur la qualité sur les mecs qui se
battent sur des mots c'est
extraordinaire ça serait joli c'est payé
s'est payé
l'académie oui oui je crois qu'on gagne
actuellement je parlais en france et en
francs par mois
combien on va rester dans la télé un
rendez compte
en quelques en quelques temps comme ça
vous êtes parti voilà de rien et bâtons
vous êtes tous dans voici
grâce à toi mais c'est pas qu'ils la
première fois comment tu les as et
comment tu les a tous les matins c'est
une histoire
coût total j'ai des jeunes avec les
frères hazanavicius et un ou deux paires
nos copains
en ski et niel que tu es ridicule car ma
femme est une actrice que j'adore à la
géniale à thiolettes ap lionel est à mes
potes et on déjeune ensemble et 18,1 tu
devrais aller voir une troupe une troupe
qui joue un robin des bois d'à peu près
à victor hugo à l'exemple du tableau -
alexandre dumas j'ai à fontainebleau
tanger quand je suis à fontainebleau ça
me fait chier je le connais de lui
peut-être même en bas on ne savait pas
par la tête jamais de ma vie j'y vais et
en fin de compte on y va on y va en
panda ou un truc comme ça c'est un peu
court ingo 36.8 voilà on trouve même pas
dans un théâtre c'était une grosse était
une grange m'assois et j'ai dû me faire
chier la dure et ça m'a fait vraiment
poil et du début jusqu'à la fin et j'ai
zappé les couacs est ce un jour après
jour de fou mais j'appelle à dire
bonjour c'est dominique farrugia et que
ouais il me raccroche aux plages et un
peu de trois fois au début on voulait
faire un film de ça j'ai ensuite j'ai
produit la pièce avec catherine risque
était super la première réunion il nous
reçoit donc il nous dit qu'il veut qu'on
écrive un scénario est tout le monde i
way d'accord on fait semblant que ça
nous fait pas peur du tout non non non
en arrivant on était comme un temps il
avait un côté il y avait 1 h à bord avec
jean pierre bacri qui au volant
vous voyez tous ces gens là cette
impression est donc et on dit et on dit
un peu intimidés ont dit oui heures
d'accord on est d'accord pour faire le
film mais est-ce que s'il vous plaît
monsieur ça vous dérangerait pas si on
joue la pièce alors lui dis bah non pas
du tout est dit vous avez ça fait un
théâtre on dit ben non elle dit mais
vous avez de l'argent du bain non mais
vous avez un producteur eddie mais
voulait que vous produisent bah ouais
d'accord cassette que le truc était
drôle c'est énorme
il m'avait donné moi vous allez voir
quelque chose pour au moins aller vendre
de spectacles dont je prendrais
rendez-vous déjà je peux leur nouvelle
idée mais qui me connaissent pas je
connais pas le monde du théâtre
ouais je la prenais un spectacle robin
des bois d'à peu près donc le maire a
remis la sua était farrugia bien sûr
encore un conte qui raccroche et je vais
voir un mec un jour dans un théâtre je
citerai pas le nom et je mets la
cassette et enfin quand j'avais jamais
regarder ses pieds et c'est un plomb
large filmée à 700 kilomètres on voit
les maîtres grand comme ça et qui parle
et le mec au bout de dix minutes
moi j'étais très gênée fait web texture
aussi la musique à un moment donc je
pense qu'on sera pas libre avoir un nom
un logo il rentre chez lui où il
réveille sa femme et
apple corps à corps il raconte tout le
dîner gala en direct en une prise et se
passe en fait c'est jacques elle
s'ennuie pas du tout hein
[Musique]
mais vous êtes vous êtes avec elle
depuis longtemps nous sommes mari le pri
vainqueur depuis 25 ans nous avons deux
enfants et ça se passe bien toujours
oui mais l'avocat
la question de cuba
et quand est-ce lourds commençaient un
beau one man show comme on aimerait
avoir
j'en attends attendez moi j'ai une idée
voilà remercie pas restée là on fait
vous faites un spectacle et un moment il
ya un deux coups j'imagine le succès
énorme que zynga vente à l'inde de coûts
qui vient raconter napoléon on s'enligne
pour cet homme le seul problème c'est
vrai qu'en ce moment on ne peux plus
m'arrêter de tourner autour
l'amour
même pas tous les soirs vous nos débuts
après les jeunes qu'on le faisait sur un
peu juste pour la prière
il ya quatre sympathie n'ai pas vu pas
du pedn un peu gros il ya un moment où
il ira non il n'y a pas un moment où on
dirait un poisson qui rentre bien dans
le monde et deux toi ça ferait une
blague moyen moyenne en deux secondes
il en fait un quart d'heure c'est un
truc différent
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux